my talk today stop writing dead programs
so this is sort of the thesis statement
for the talk even though it's 40 years
old this Seymour password quote saying
that we're still digging ourselves into
a kind of a pit by continuing to
preserve practices that have no rational
basis Beyond being historical
so I will start with a somewhat personal
journey in technology I'm going to ask
you for some feedback at some different
places so first off buy Applause how
many of you know what this is
okay okay that's that's actually more
than I expected now how many of you
actually used one of these
okay so what I can say is that I am part
of the last generation of people who
were forced to use Punch Cards at school
I still had to write Fortran programs
with Punch Cards and this thing is a
card punch right so it's like a keyboard
except when you press the keys you're
actually making holes in a piece of
paper and the p and then you feed them
into this thing in the back here and the
pieces of paper look like this so each
one of these vertical columns is
basically a byte and you're stabbing
through the different uh bits of the
bite to indicate what letter it is if
you look at the top left corner there
you see Zed one sub one equal y plus W
sub one so this is one line of code a
card is one line of code something to
notice about this card it's 80 columns
wide we're going to come back to that
later
and this design dates from when from
1928 this is a hollow Earth punch card
same one used forever now what does a
program look like if you're programming
like this it looks like this it's a deck
now notice the rubber band when you're
doing this you live in terminal fear
that you will drop the deck of cards it
is it is a terrible experience resorting
the cards that long diagonal stripe
there is so that this person who made
this particular deck could put it back
together without having to look at every
single line in the process and the words
written on the top of the deck are sort
of indicating where different
subroutines are located within this
now to give you a sense of how long
these programs can get this picture I
forgive me it's a low quality picture
this is the actual reader I used and
that in the front there is an actual
program I wrote the lower right hand
corner one which was a Fortran program
to simulate rocket flight because my my
particular school had a connection to
NASA and we did a lot of Rocket things
right so can you imagine how long it
took me to punch all these and put them
in there and what we would do is give
them to a system operator who would feed
them into a computer in this case the
computer I personally used was this one
this is a vax 11780 this machine costs
nearly a million dollars had 16
megabytes that's megabytes of ram ran at
five megahertz that's megahertz this
thing in front of me here is thousands
of times more powerful than the machine
that I was using then that the whole
campus was using to do these kinds of
things then and what would the output
look like that came from sending this
enormous deck of cards in well it would
come out on a teletype that looks like
this right and you wouldn't get it right
away an operator would give it to you
later note the Vintage haircuts the
yellow in the middle there is the actual
operator who was handing me these
outputs and he's the person who gave me
these photos of this equipment
so this process as you can imagine was
hard but it was hard in a dumb way right
some things are hard because they have
to be and I really support the idea of
overcoming challenges and doing hard
things but this was hard
for reasons had nothing to do with the
actual problem right you're trying to do
something with a rocket and a simulation
and you're thinking about not dropping
your punch card deck and it's taking you
forever to find out what happened so it
really hinges on your ability to emulate
the computer in your head because the
computer's not going to help you in any
way there's not an editor there's
nothing and that in turn hinges on
working memory which is something that
is not very well distributed among
humans so there were a small number of
us for whom this whole thing came pretty
naturally and we were treated as like
special people as kind of high priests
with magical powers and this is how we
came to think of ourselves right that
we're special that we can make it work
but the truth is we were less priests
like this than we were monks like this
hitting ourselves in the head
right but the problem is
as Peter Harkins mentions here that
programmers have this tendency to once
they Master something hard often
pointlessly hard rather than then making
it easy they feel proud of themselves
for having done it and just perpetuate
the hard nonsense and I'm going to argue
that a lot of what we still do today is
very much like what I was doing on that
old vax for one thing there's a lot of
batch processing going on right and
what's wrong with batch processing hella
long feedback loops it's no good takes
you forever it took me 45 minutes to
find out what a one card change would do
in the printout that I would get back
because that was the loop right I'm
thinking well it's not like that for us
right we're not poking holes in paper
cards we have like display terminals but
how many of you guys have like compile
cycles that can take 45 minutes famously
the whole go team wrote go because they
were so angry about waiting for an hour
because they wanted to see what was
going to happen with some C plus plus
code they're running on some horrible
giant Google code base or maybe you want
to deploy your stuff and see if it works
because we're all running web apps now
right so do you like stuff it in a
Docker container and then ship it out to
the cloud and wait for a CI job how long
does that that take
two hours for this guy I mean why do we
tolerate this this is crazy Docker
shouldn't exist it exists only because
everything else is so terribly
complicated that they added another
layer of complexity to make it work it's
like they thought if deployment is bad
we should make development bad too it's
just it's no good
so what kind of things do we inherit
from this way of thinking about the
world we get funny ideas that are built
into programming about time and state
ideas like there should be a compile Run
Cycle this is a terrible idea but it's
an ancient idea that you're going to
compile the thing and you're getting an
artifact and you're going to run the
artifact over there and those two things
are completely different phases of your
process right there's going to be linear
execution most programming languages
assume that there's only one thread and
you're going to run straight through
from the beginning to the end that your
program is going to start up from a
blank State and then run determination
now how many programs that we actually
write do that we'll revisit that in a
moment this really only works if your
program is some kind of input output
Transformer right so there's no runtime
introspection because runtime is
happening over there and your actual
work is happening over here and you just
have to kind of guess from what happened
how it might be related to your code and
if there's a bug well sorry failures
just halt your program you get maybe a
core dump or you get a log message
somewhere with a stack Trace in it now
what kind of programs do we really write
mostly long-lived servers I've got
server processes with up times of a
thousand days
they don't they don't work the same way
user bin sort works right I don't want a
process that's optimized for writing
that we also write GUI programs GUI
programs are more intense than this even
right so you've got all of these
different kinds of input coming into the
program and it's maybe it's talking to
the keyboard it's talking to the mouse
it's talking to the network if it's Zoom
it's talking to the camera it's talking
to the microphone it's crazy so these
kind this approach to programming just
doesn't work well for the things we
actually build it also infected
programming language Theory so if the
program is a static artifact what does
that mean it means we're mostly going to
concentrate on algebraic so we're going
to talk about syntax and semantics and
very little else
there's going to be no concern really
for pragmatics and what I mean here by
pragmatics is what it's actually like to
interact with your programming
environment and this leads to
mathematics envy and a real fixation on
theorem proving
so to give an example of what happens
when people actually concentrate on a
part of programming and make progress
we're going to take a quick tour through
syntax and semantics we're going to do a
simple transformation here right we've
got one through four we want it to be
two through five we want it to be
relatively General I've written some
example programs that do this in a
variety of programming languages so the
first one here is it is an arm64 machine
language because my laptop happens to
run this processor now as you can
plainly see from this code it starts off
oh wait does everyone here understand
rm64 okay all right it's a little easier
if I do this so you can see where the
instructions are within these different
words this is a cool instruction set
it's not like Intel Intel all the
instructions are different lengths in
arm they're all the same length because
it's a risk but we'll do it in Assembly
Language it'll be easier right so we
we'll start with this label here add one
and we've got the signature of what it
would be as a c program after that so
what am I actually doing when I write
this program well the first thing I'm
doing is moving things from registers
onto the stack why am I doing this I'm
doing this because the ABI says I have
to no other reason it's nothing to do
with my problem and then I want to call
Malik because I have to allocate some
memory to return the new you know array
with the new stuff in it so what I have
to do
I'm doing crazy things look down here
you see the registers are all called
with X names right that's because
there's 64-bit registers at X but I get
down here to set up for Malik and now
I'm using W names why well I just have
to know that I have to do something
special if it's a 32-bit number and
it'll mask off 32 of the bits and still
work great so now I have to stuff things
in these registers I have to multiply
one of the variables do I use a multiply
for that no I'm using it with a bit
shifting operation because that's what's
faster on this processor and then I call
Malik and I get back what I want great
now I want a loop this is what a loop
looks like notice we're on the second
page and all I'm doing is incrementing
some numbers right so I come through and
I do a comparison okay is this register
that I put this value into the zero if
it's less than I jump to return you
can't see return it's on another page
there's a third page
so I move zero into this other register
and I go through here and bang bang I'm
I'm not going to bore you with the whole
thing I'm bored just talking about it
imagine how I felt writing it
and then at the end I have to do the
reverse of the things I did at the
beginning to set everything back into
the registers from the stack where I
saved them why because I have to have
the right return address to give this
thing back I have to do this like a
voodoo incantation because it's what the
processor wants nothing to do with the
problem I'm trying to solve how can we
do it better hey look at C this is
exactly the same program many fewer
lines of code however it has a load of
problems that have nothing to do with
what I'm trying to accomplish as well
for one I have to pass two things I have
to pass the length of the array separate
from the array why because there's no
sequence type in C great work guys so
then from there I want to return this
value this modified sequence and what do
I have to do well I had to do this
assembly too but this is crazy I have to
allocate memory give it back and then
hope that the other guy is going to free
that memory later this has nothing to do
with what I'm trying to accomplish I
want to increment each of these numbers
I do it with a for Loop that counts from
one to the length of the array is
counting to the length of the array
relevant from right no no this is
relevant in fact no essentially one line
of code of this whole thing the actual
increment is the only thing that
actually matters on the other hand I can
complement c as a portable Assembly
Language because you see I don't have to
do the stack nonsense by hand and
instead of telling it that it's four
bytes wide I can actually use size of
ant to know that but that's about the
only way it's really an improvement now
let's look at lisp note that lisp is
about 10 years older than C here I have
a sequence abstraction right I have four
numbers and I can make I can use a
higher order function go over it and add
one to each of them this is a tremendous
Improvement by going back in time but we
do
but we can do better we can do better
than this notation right we can go to
Haskell so in Haskell what do we have
this is really lovely we have this thing
where we Otto Curry the plus one and we
get a function that adds one this is
getting pretty concise can anybody here
quickly name for me a language in which
this exact operation is even more
concise I'll give you a moment
I hear APL and indeed APL so here we
have Road polymorphism here I have an I
have a single number
a scalar and I have a set of numbers
note that there's no stupid junk I don't
have to put commas between everything I
don't have to wrap anything in any
special Terminators or anything of this
nature I just say add one to these
numbers and I get what I was after so if
we start from the Assembly Language and
we come to the APO which is you know
again you know like eight years older
than C we find that syntax and semantics
can take us a long way
but there are other things that we care
about where no one has put in this much
effort and one of those things is State
and time so almost every programming
language doesn't do anything to help us
with managing State over time for
multiple sources there are some notable
exceptions I will talk about them now so
closure
[Music]
uh because Richard he really cared about
conturrency he included immutable data
structures so now you don't have
constant banging on the same things and
crushing each other's data this is very
helpful what else he's got atoms these
are synchronized mutable boxes with
functional update sematics everybody
uses these These are great he has also a
full software and transactional memory
implementation that frankly nobody uses
but it's still great it just has a more
complicated API and the lesson from this
probably is if you want people to do the
right thing you have to give them API
simple enough that they really will
then on top of this we have core async
now I have I have less nice things to
say about query sync right I like
communicating experimental processes the
way everybody else does but this is
implemented as a macro and as a
consequence when it compiles your CSP
code you end up with something that you
can't really look into anymore like you
can't ask a channel how many things are
in that channel you can't really know
much about what's happening there and I
would say that in the jvm I agree with
what rich said the year before he
created core async which is that you
should just probably use the built-in
concurrent cues
uh now on in closure script of course
these things were more useful because
everyone was trapped in callback hell
we'll see what happens moving on now
that we have async awake in JavaScript
now moving on to another implementation
of CSP go go actually did something good
here right they and I'm not going to say
much else that's great about go uh is
the
is they built a fantastic run time for
this stuff it it's really lightweight it
does a great job the bad news is that go
is a completely static language so even
though you should be able to go in and
ask all of these questions during
runtime while you're developing from
within your editor like a civilized
person you can't you end up with a
static artifact well that's a bummer
okay
uh and I would say actually before I
move on that that anytime you have this
kind of abstraction where you have a
bunch of threads running when you have
processes doing things you really want
PS and you really want kill and
unfortunately neither go nor closure can
provide these because their run times
don't believe in them uh the the jvm
runtime itself thinks that if you kill a
process you're going to leak some
resources and the least resources you
leak may include locks that you need to
free up other other threads that are
running elsewhere so they've just
forbidden the whole thing and go you
have to send it a message to open a
separate Channel blah blah blah
erlang on the other hand gets almost
everything right in this carriage in
this situation they've implemented the
actor model and they've done it in a way
where you have a live interactive
runtime and because they're using shared
nothing for their state and supervisor
trees you can kill anything anytime and
your system will just keep running this
is fantastic this is great why doesn't
everything work like this right it also
comes with introspection tools like
Observer that should make anyone using
any other platform to build a
long-running server thing fairly jealous
now when I say this I'm not telling you
you should use erlang what I'm telling
you is whatever you use should be at
least as good as erlang at doing this
and if you're developing a new language
for God's sake please take notice
now I can talk now about something that
I worked on with my colleague Matt
Hubert this is something that I
particularly like and this is a hack in
closure script we call it cells and it
takes spreadsheet like dataflow and adds
it into closure and this resulted in a
paper that was delivered at PX 16
workshop at ecoop in Rome in 2016. so
you've got things like this right so you
say here's an interval every 300
milliseconds give me another random
integer and it does and then you can
have another thing refer to that in this
case kansing them on and now we build a
history of all the random integers that
have happened what else can you do well
you can refer to that and you can take
10 with normal closure semantics and
then map that out as a bar what do you
get you get a nice graph a graph that
moves in real time or we can move on to
this we added sort of Brett Victor style
scrubbers into it so that you could do
these kinds of things I'll show you
instead of telling you because it's
obvious if you look at it what's going
on here and we did this partially to
show people that you can just really
program with systems that have all those
features that Brett was demoing
Source code's still out there anybody
wants to do that you can do that now we
moved on from that to maria.cloud which
takes all of that code we wrote for
cells and turns it into a notebook we
actually did this for Learners so take a
look at this so this is a computational
notebook it has the cells it gives you
much better error messages than fault
closure and so on we use this to teach
it was a great experience and currently
this year thanks to closures together we
have some additional funding to bring it
up to date and keep it running I
encourage everybody to check it out the
last thing here on this list is the
propagators now the propagators come
from Sussman this is uh sussman's
project from around the same time that
actors were happening and K was first
getting interested in small talk this
was a really fertile scene at MIT in the
early 70s uh it was actually the project
he originally hired Richard Stahlman of
the new project as a grad student to
work on and then later did some
additional work with Alexi radul which
expanded the whole thing
I can't tell you all about it here
there's just too much to say but I can
tell you there was a fantastic talk at
the 2011 strange Loop called we still
don't know how to compute and I
recommend that you watch that when you
get out of strange Loop just go home and
watch that talk it's amazing a side
thing is that the propagator model was
used by one of the grad students at MIT
at the time to make the very first
spreadsheet visicalc was based on this
model this is a really useful
abstraction that everyone should know
about it's data flow based it does truth
maintenance and it keeps provenance of
where all of the conclusions the truth
maintenance system came from which means
it's probably going to be very valuable
for explainable AI later
now we'll move to another area where
there's been even less progress okay so
now we're getting to the the absolute
nature of progress here that's in
program representation let's look at
that punch card again
80 columns there it is
now look at this this is the output of a
teletype notice that it is fixed width
and approximately 80 columns notice that
the fonts are all fixed with
this is the teletype in question
this looks like it should be in a museum
and it should be in a museum and in fact
is in a museum
we got these so this is the terminal in
which I did a lot of hacking on that vax
that you saw earlier when I wasn't
forced to use Punch Cards and a lot of
that was in languages like vax Pascal
yeah but also Bliss which was pretty
cool so you'll notice that this is a
vt100 terminal here and all of you are
using machines today that have terminal
emulators that pretend to be this
terminal that's why they have vt100
Escape codes because those Escape codes
first shipped on this terminal now we'll
move on to another terminal this is the
one that I used when I was doing all of
my early Unix hacking back in the 80s
this is called an adm3a Now by by
Applause how many of you use an editor
that has VI key bindings come on yeah
all right yeah so then you might be
interested in the keyboard of the adm3a
which was the one that Bill Joy had at
home to connect to school through a
modem while he was writing VI so here it
is note the arrow keys on the hjkl
they are there because those are the
control codes to move the roller and the
printhead on the old teletype that you
saw a moment ago so you'd hit Control
Plus those to control a remote teletype
it happened to have the arrow keys he
used them look where the control key is
for all you Unix people it's right next
to the a to this day on this
supercomputer here I bind the caps lock
key to control because it makes my life
easier on my Unix machine that it is
look up there where the Escape key is by
the queue that's why use escape to get
into command mode in VI because it was
easily accessible Now scan across the
top row just right of the zero What's
that the unshifted asterisk is the colon
that's why that's what it does in VI
because it was right there and now the
last one for all the Unix people in the
audience in the upper right hand corner
there's a button where when you hit
control on that button it would clear
the screen and take the cursor to the
home position if you did not hit control
instead hit shift you got the tilde
notice tilde is right under home if
you're wondering why your home directory
is tilde whatever username is it's
because of this keyboard
hahaha
now here is terminal.app on my mega
supercomputer notice 80 Columns of fixed
width type notice that when I look at
the processes they have ttys that stands
for teletype
this machine is cosplaying as a PDP 11.
[Applause]
now whenever I get exercised about this
and talk about it somebody sends me this
blog post from Graydon horror right he's
talking like oh he's bet on text he
makes good arguments I love text I use
text every day text is good the thing
about it though is that the people who
send me this in support of text always
mean text like this text like it came
out of a teletype never text like
Newton's principia never text like this
from Wolfgang vinegar that is these
people don't even know what text is
capable of they're denying the
possibilities of the medium
this is how I feel about that I've
promised Alex I will not say anything
profane during this talk so you will be
seeing this Emoji again
the reason I disagree with this position
is because the visual cortex exists okay
so this guy this this adorable little
fella he branched off from our lineage
about 60 million years ago note the
little touchy fingers in The Giant Eyes
just like we have we've had a long time
with the visual cortex it is very
powerful it is like a GPU accelerated
supercomputer of the brain whereas the
part that takes in the words is like a
very serial slow single thread CPU and I
will give you all a demonstration right
now
take a look at this teletype compatible
text of this data and tell me if any
sort of pattern emerges do you see
anything interesting
here it is plotted X Y your brain knew
this was a dinosaur before you knew that
your brain knew this was a dinosaur
right that is how powerful the visual
cortex is and there are loads of people
who have spent literally hundreds of
years getting very good at this data
visualization if I gave you a table
talking about the troop strength of
Napoleon on his March 2 and from Moscow
you'd get kind of a picture but if you
look at it like this you know what kind
of tragedy it was you can see right away
this was 175 years ago and we're still
doing paper tape right so
graphic designers they know something
they know a few things for instance they
know that these are all channels these
different things point line plane
organization asymmetry that these things
are all channels that get directly to
our brain and there is no need to issue
these forms of representation when we're
talking about program representation so
I recommend everyone in this audience
who hasn't already done so go just get
this 100 year old book from Kandinsky
and get a sense of what's possible
here's one of his students working on
some notation look how cool that is come
on all right so another thing with text
is that it's really bad at doing graphs
with cycles and our world is full of
graphic Cycles so like here's a closure
notation idea of the the taxonomy of
animals including us in that cute little
tarse before and it works fine because
it's a tree and trees are really good at
containment they can do containment in a
single acyclic manner now this this
sucks to write down as text this is the
Krebs cycle hopefully all of you learned
this at school if not maybe read up on
it so
if you imagine trying to explain this
with paragraphs of text you would never
get anywhere our doctors would all fair
we would all be dead so instead we draw
a picture we should be able to draw
pictures when we're coding as well
here's the periodic table look how
beautiful this is this is 1976. we've
got all the channels working together to
tell us things about all these these
different different elements uh interact
with each other
so another area that we've pretty much
ignored is pragmatics and what I mean by
that I'm borrowing it from Linguistics
and because we've borrowed syntax and
somatics from Linguistics pragmatics is
studying like the relationship between a
language and the users of the language
and I'm using it here to talk about
programming environments
so specifically I want to talk about
interactive programming which is I think
the only kind of programming we should
really be doing some people call it live
coding mainly in the art community and
this is when you code with what Dan
Ingalls refers to as liveness it is the
opposite of batch processing instead
there is a programming environment there
and the environment of the program are
combined during development so what does
this do for us well there's no compile
and Run Cycle you're compiling inside
your running program so you no longer
have that feedback loop weight it
doesn't start with a blank slate and run
determination instead all of your
program state is still there while
you're working on it this means that you
can debug you can add things to it you
can find out what's going on all while
your program is running
of course there's runtime introspection
right and failures don't halt the
program they give you some kind of
option to maybe fix and continue what's
happening now this combination of
attributes I would say is most of what
makes spreadsheets so productive
and it gives you these incredibly short
feedback loops of which we'll now have
some examples if you're compiling some
code say in common lisp you can compile
the code and disassemble it and see
exactly what you got now the program is
running the program is alive right now
and I'm asking questions of that runtime
and I look at this and I say okay well
36 bytes that's too much right so I'll
go through and I'll add some some you
know optimizations to it recompile okay
16 bytes that's about as many
instructions as I want to spend on this
right
so I know a bunch of you are probably
allergic to us Expressions here's Julia
you can do exactly the same thing in
Julia look at this you get the native
code back for the thing that you just
made and you can change it while it's
running
now what about types this is where half
of you store them off in Anger right so
I'm going to show you this tweet and I
wouldn't be quite this uncharitable but
I broadly agree with this position
so it's a lot of fun like I have I've
been programming for 45 years I have
shipped o camel I have shipped Haskell I
love Haskell actually I think it's great
but I would say that over those many
decades I have not really seen the
programs in these languages to have any
fewer defects than programs in any other
programming language that I use modulo
the ones with really bad memory
allocation Behavior
and there has been considerable
empirical study of this question and
there has been no evidence it really
doesn't seem to matter so if you like
programming in those languages that's
great I encourage you to do it you
should program it whatever you enjoy but
you shouldn't pretend that you have a
moral High Ground because you've chosen
this particular language and I would say
really that if what you care about is
systems that are highly fault tolerant
you should be using something like
erlang over something like Haskell
because the facilities erlang provides
are more likely to give you working
programs
you can throw fruit at me brought fruit
at me later you can find me in the
hallway track to tell me how wrong I am
so I'll I've said that but I'll also
show you probably the most beautiful
piece of program that I've ever seen
like the best source code in the world
and that's McElroy's power series which
happens to be written in Pascal so this
is a mutually recursive definition of
the series of sine and cosine in two
lines of code I want to cry when I look
at this because of how beautiful it is
but that has nothing to do with software
engineering do you understand what I'm
saying there's a different question the
beauty of the language is not always
what gets you to where you need to go
now I will make a an exception here for
model Checkers because you know
Protocols are super hard it's a good
idea to try to verify them I've used
[ __ ] and teapot for these kinds of
things in the past and some systems do
have such a high cost of failure that it
makes sense to use them like if you're
doing some kind of you know horrible
cryptocurrency thing where you're likely
to lose a billion dollars worth of
something coin it then you yeah you
maybe want to use some kind of verifier
to make sure you're not going to screw
it up but that said
space probes written in Lisbon fourth
have been debugged while off world right
so if they had if they had proved their
programs correct by construction and
shipped into space and then found out
their spec was wrong they would have
just had some dead junk on Mars but what
these guys had was the ability to fix
things while they are running on space
probes I think that's actually more
valuable again throw the rotten fruit
later meet me in the hallway track
now I would say overall that part of
this is because programming is actually
a design discipline it oh we're losing
somebody somebody's leaving now probably
out of anger about static types
as a design discipline you find that you
will figure out what you're building as
you build it right you don't actually
know when you start even if you think
you do so it's important that we build
buggy approximations on the way and I
think it's not the best use of your time
to prove theorems about code that you're
going to throw away anyway in addition
the spec is always wrong it doesn't
matter where you got it or who said it
the only complete set spec for any
non-trivial system is the source code of
the system itself we learn through
iteration and when the Spec's right it's
still wrong because the software will
change tomorrow all software is
continuous change the spec today is not
the spec to tomorrow which leads me to
say that overall debuggability is in my
opinion more important than correctness
by construction so let's talk about
debugging
so I would say that actually most
programming is debugging what do we
spend our time to do time doing these
days well we're spending a lot of time
with other people's libraries we're
dealing with API endpoints we're dealing
with huge Legacy code bases and we're
spending all our time like this robot
detective trying to find out what's
actually happening in the code and we do
that with exploratory programming
because it reduces the amount of
suffering involved so for example in a
dead coding language I will have to run
a separate debugger load in the program
and run it set a break point and get it
here now if I've had a fault in
production this is not actually so
helpful to me maybe I have a core dump
and the core dump has some information
that I could use but it doesn't show me
the state of things while it's running
now here's some common lisp look I set
this variable look I inspect this
variable on the bottom I see the value
of the variable this is valuable to me
right I like this and indeed here we
have a way to look at a whole set of
nested data structures graphically we
can actually see things note in
particular the complex double float at
the bottom that shows you a geometric
interpretation
so this is amazing this is also 1980s
technology you should be ashamed if
you're using a programming language that
doesn't give you this at run time
speaking of programming languages they
do give you this at runtime here is a
modern version enclosure you're somebody
doing a data log query and getting back
some information and graphing it as they
go I will say the closure is slightly
less good at this than common list but
Present part of it is the convolution
object system makes it particularly easy
to have good presentations for different
kinds of things but at least it's in the
right direction
now as we talk about this one of the
things in these kinds of programming
languages like list is that you have an
editor you're evaluating forms all the
closure parameters and there's going to
know this right off those people and so
on you're evaluating forms and they're
being added to the runtime as you go and
this is great it's a fantastic way to
build up a program but there's a real
problem with it which is that if you
delete some of that code the same thing
that you just evaluated earlier is still
in the runtime so it would be great if
there were a way that we could know what
is current rather than having say a text
file that grows gradually out of sync
with the running system and that's
called small talk and has been around
since at least the 70s so this is the
small talk object browser here we're
looking at dijkstra's algorithm
specifically we're looking at
backtracking uh in the shortest path
algorithm and if I change this I know I
changed it I know what's happening if I
delete this method the method is gone
it's no longer visible so there is a
direct correspondence between what I'm
doing and what what the system knows and
what I'm seeing in front of me right and
this is very powerful and here we have
the Glamorous toolkit this is tutor
gibber and feeks thing they Embrace this
philosophy completely they have built an
enormous Suite of visualizations that
allow you to find out things about your
program while it's running we should all
take inspiration from this this is an
ancient tradition and they have kind of
taken this old thing of small talkers
and lispers building their own tools
they go to understand their own code
bases and they have sort of pushed it
they've pushed the pedal all the way to
the floor and they're rushing forward
into the future and we should follow
them
so another thing that is very useful in
these situations is error handling if
your error handling is the program stops
then it's pretty hard to recover right
but in a commonless program like this
this is an incredibly stupid toy example
but I have a version function I have not
actually evaluated the function yet I'm
going to try to call it so what's going
to happen well the CL people here know
what's going to happen it's going to pop
up the condition Handler so this is
something that programming enclosure
actually really missed from common lisp
so it comes up and I have options here I
can type in the value of a specific
function say hey call this one instead
for the missing function I can try again
which if I don't change anything will
just give me the same condition Handler
or I can change the state of the running
image and then try again so for example
if I go down and evaluate the function
so that it's now defined and hit retry
it just works this is pretty amazing we
should all expect this from our
programming environments again when I
talk about small talking list people say
well I don't want to use multiple I'm
not telling you to use small talker
Lisbon telling you that you should have
programming languages that are at least
as good as small talk and Liz
so some people when I show them all this
stuff all this interactive stuff they're
like well what if I just had a real fast
compiler man you know I can just I can
just change and hit a key and then the
things that well we're back to that
emoji again because if you have a fast
compiler you still have all the problems
with the Blank Slate Run determination
style things like data science workloads
take a long time to initialize you might
have a big data load and you don't want
to have to do that every single time you
make a change to your code and the data
science people know this this is why R
is interactive this is why we have
notebooks for Python and other languages
because they know it's crazy to work
this other way also GUI State oh my word
it can be incredibly tedious to click
your way back down to some Sub Sub menu
so that you can get to the part where
the thing is you want to just keep it
right where it is and go in and see
what's happening behind the scenes and
fix it while it's running
also you should be able to attach to
long-running servers and debug them
while they're in production this is
actually good it's scary to people who
are easily frightened but it is very
powerful
now I'll say after all of this about
interactive programming about escaping
batch mode that almost all programming
today is still batch mode and how do we
feel about that I kind of feel like lick
lighter did so lick lighter funded
almost all of the work that created the
world we live in today and engelbart
built half of it and one of the things
that lick lighter said that I found I
just love the phrase is getting into
position to think that is all of the
ceremony that you have to go through to
get ready to do your work should go away
and that was their whole mission in the
60s
we almost got there but then we have
languages like C plus
now I could say a lot of mean things
about C plus plus I used to work at the
same facility that Bjorn did and I kind
of know him a little bit but I'm not
going to do that instead
I I'm just going to quote Ken Thompson
so yeah
so this is a really funny situation
because I worked on some of the early C
plus plus compilers because I was
excited about the idea of having decent
abstractions in a low-level language
that I could use but I will say that it
was never great and that it has gotten
worse over time paradoxically by adding
good features to the language that but
if you keep adding every feature that
you possibly want you want you end up
with a language that is not in any way
principled there is no way to reason
about it it has too much junk in it and
if you'd like to see this happening in
real time to another language I
recommend that you read what's going on
in tc39 with JavaScript where they are
adding every possible feature and
muddying an already difficult language
further
so what about go well I admire the
runtime and the go routines the garbage
collector but it's really another punch
card compatible compile run language it
shared and it also shares with C plus
plus the problem that it's not a great
Library language because if you want to
write a library and go and then use it
from say a c program or whatever you
have to bring in the entire go run time
which is a couple Megs not mostly what I
want so what about rust well I mean it's
a nice thing that rust is a good Library
language I like that about it but it's
also a huge missed opportunity in terms
of interactive programming they just
went straight for the punch cards again
and it's a super super complicated
language and so it would be nice when
trying to figure out which of the 40
different memory allocation keywords
you're going to use to tell it how to do
its thing if you could explore that
interactively instead of going through a
compile test cycle and another way that
I feel about it I have to quote ditch
here which is that you know some people
hate stop the world GC I really hate
stop the world type Checkers right if
it's going to take me an hour to compile
my thing I just want to give up I'm
going to become a carpenter or something
you know now in this family of languages
I'll say that Zig is more to my taste I
actually like say big more than I like
for us this will anger all of the
restations I apologize but it is true
but Zig people for goodness sake why is
there no interactive story there either
you've got this nice little language
that has multi-stage compilation it can
learn a lot from lisp and it just sort
of ignores all that and goes straight to
the you know to the 1970s or before
so what do future directions that don't
suck look like well I'll give you some
examples that have that try to use some
of the things I've talked about as
underexplored areas right so this this
is a structure editor for racket which
is a dialect of scheme and it was built
by a fellow called Andrew Blinn and it's
still racket underneath that is it's
still a lot of parentheses it's still s
Expressions but when you're editing it
you have this completely different
feeling where you're modifying this
living structure and it's quite colorful
and beautiful probably for some of you
garish but I like it
and I recommend having a peek at how
that works and compare it to how you're
editing code now another example that I
think will be more accessible to this
audience is this one from Leif Anderson
this is also Racket and this is doing a
defined using pattern matching for red
black tree balancing algorithm and it is
an ancient practice of many years to
document gnarly code like this with a
comment block over it but you have a
couple of problems one the comment block
is ugly and not completely obviously
meeting what it's supposed to mean but
also it can grow out of sync with the
code itself so Leaf has made this fine
thing that reads the code and produces
these diagrams and you can switch the
diagram view on or off and so this is
what if we want to talk about
self-documenting code I would say
something like this that can actually
show you what the code does is better
than what most things do
in the same vein we've got this piece
this is uh called Data rabbit data
rabbit is a crazy data visualization
thing written enclosure each one of
these little blocks that are connected
by these tubes is actually a little
piece of closure code and they can do
data visualization they can do
refinement they can do all of these nice
things now I'm not a huge you know box
and arrow programming language guy but I
think that Ryan has done great work here
and that everybody should take a look at
it
there's also clerk now I'm a bit biased
here this is something I work on this is
something I've been working on for the
last year with the team at next Journal
but I think it is actually very good so
I'm going to tell you a little something
about it
so this is this is what it looks like
when you're working a clerk you've got
whatever editor you want on one side and
then you've got a view onto the contents
of the namespace you're working on off
to the side this has some special
properties it means for one thing that
you can put these notebooks into Version
Control you can ship these notebooks
these can be libraries that you use you
don't have this separation between your
notebook code and your production code
they can be the same thing and it
encourages a kind of literate
programming approach where every comment
along the way or every comment block
along the way is interpreters markdown
with the tech and other features like
that it's it's a very nice way to work I
encourage the closure people here to
check it out is of no use to you if
you're not a closure person because it's
very closure specific and I'll show you
a couple of other screenshots here like
this we're doing some data science and
you've got your that's my emacs on the
right hand side and I'm able to do all
of the things like pretty printing data
structures and inspecting them and then
sending things over and seeing them in
Clerk and it is a very cozy way to work
there's also for instance this example
where in around six lines of code I do a
query for some bioinformatic information
that shows me what
what drugs affect what genes that are
known to be correlated with what
diseases so they can see what drugs
might be interesting targets for genetic
disorders of differing type right if 20
years ago if you would have told people
they'd be able to do a single query like
this and find these kinds of things out
they would have looked at you like had
two heads but here it is and it's no
code at all or this which is a port of
sussman's structure and interpretation
of classical mechanics uh Library into
closure that you can use inside of Clerk
and then do things with physics like
real things this is emulating a cadetic
system and you can actually you can't
see on this but you can actually grab
sliders and move them around and change
the state of the system in real time
it'll show you what's happening
or this Martin here in the front row
wrote this so this is a example of rule
30 which is cellular automata and he's
written a viewer for it so instead of
looking at ones and zeros you can
actually see the thing he's working on
and the amount of code this takes is
almost none
this is a regular expression dictionary
that I wrote so this thing one of the
nice things about clerk is you have all
the groovy visualization interactive
things that come from having a browser
but you also have all the power of
closure running on the jvm on the other
side so you can do things like talk to a
database on the file system which is a
revelation compared to what you can
normally do with a browser
so with this uh this kind of thing you
can do rapid application development you
can do all kinds of things and I will
add that clerk actually improves on the
execution semantics that you normally
get with emacs enclosure this is inside
baseball for the closure people sorry
for everybody else but that thing I was
talking about about how you can add
things to the running image and then
delete the code and then they're not
there and you don't know it and maybe
you save your program it doesn't work
the next time you start clerk will not
use things that you've removed from the
file it actually reports that so you get
errors when you have gotten your text
out of sync with your running image
now obviously I have a huge list bias I
happen to love list but it's not just
lists there are other people doing good
things so this is called Hazel this is
from cairos Omar's team uh you see those
little question marks after the function
there this is no camel or elm-like
language and they do something called
typed holes where they're actually
running interactively their type
inference and using it for its in my
opinion strongest purpose which is
improving user interface so here when
you go to put something into one of
these typed holes it knows what type
it's going to be and it's going to give
you hints and it's going to help you do
it and they've taken that to build this
nice student interface so if you're
going to teach students through design
recipes that involve type-based thinking
then you should have a thing like this
that actually helps them in some way and
the one they've made is very good I
recommend reading the papers now he has
a student called David Moon who has made
this this is called Tyler I can't really
show you this in a good way without
video so I recommend that you go to
David Moon's Twitter and you scroll
through and you look at some of these
things but it's got a beautiful
structure editing component that
prevents you from screwing up your code
syntactically while you're working on it
and gives you advice based on type
information
so here this is my absolute favorite
from cairosomers group this is also by
David Moon who did the structure editor
and Andrew Blinn who did the nice editor
for scheme that we saw at the beginning
of this section so here we have again an
ocamular elm-like language but you can
put these uh these little widgets in
these are called livelits with the
syntactical affordance here is they
begin with a with a dollar sign and so
he's got some data here and the data
showed as a data frame it's like
actually a convenient nice to edit thing
and it's in line with the source code so
this this is a thing where you can have
more expressive Source Code by allowing
you to overlap different views onto the
source code you can also see there's a
slider in there and the slider is
immediately compute the the rest of the
values are immediately recomputed when
the slider slides in a data flow kind of
way this is a great project I hope they
do more of it here's something a little
crazier so this is Enzo Enzo is groovy
because it is a functional programming
language that has two representations it
is projectional so it is not just this
kind of lines between boxes thing but
it's a line between boxes and then you
can flip it over and see the code that
corresponds to those things you can edit
either side and it fixes both
and now we'll go on to our last example
from this section which is also the
craziest one and that is Hest by Ivan
Reese so here we're Computing factorial
but we're doing it with animation so we
see these values flowing through the
system in this way and splitting based
on uh based on criteria that are
specified in the code and we're working
up to a higher and higher factorial now
I look at this and I don't say yeah
that's how I want to program right I
want to spend every day in this thing
but what I've learned if nothing else
over the very long career that I've had
is if you see something that looks
completely insane and a little bit like
Outsider Art you're probably looking at
something that has good ideas so whether
or not we ever want to work like this we
shouldn't ignore it
and this was my last example for today
so I have some thank yous to do first
I'd like to thank Alex for inviting me
to give this talk I'd like to thank next
journal for sponsoring my work including
the writing of this talk and I would
like to thank all of you for watching
thank you very much
[Applause]